happy hump day everyone we have eight
new official game of thrones photos
just released today so we are gonna
break these babies down
and see what clues they can offer us for
the pen ultimate episode
now about two or three of these images
are simply stills taken from the preview
trailer
so i'm not going to waste your time with
those but if you're interested check out
my preview breakdown in the link
description
so let's get into it i want to start
with the photo which i believe occurs
the earliest in the episode
we see a wider shot of this in the
preview but it's of daenerys looking for
lorne as
tyrion watches on my guess is that she
is struggling with the decision of
having to use her dragon to burn king's
landing to the ground
a decision which would result in the
deaths of thousands of civilians
she was originally against this idea but
with the deaths of rhaegal and missandei
especially missandei whose last words
were dracarus aka
dragonfire it seems like this is the
most likely scenario
which leads us to the next photo tyrion
in dragonstone
my guess is this lines up with the other
new shot of grey worm
both of whom are in the throne room
notice here it's daytime not
night like we saw in the preview the
candelabra behind greyworm here has not
been lit like it is in the preview
suggesting we'll have at least two
separate scenes with daenerys
and her advisors before the invasion of
king's landing
now look at tyrion here this is not a
happy look
there's almost a bit of shock in it as
if he's taking in some new information
from daenerys
as i theorized i believe dany will
invade king's landing with her dragon
even though the amount of potential
civilian deaths will be extremely high
this is something tyrion has been
against and will likely cause friction
between the two a friction which has
been building since the beginning of
this season
cersei still sits on the throne if you
can't help me take it back
i'll find another hand you can gray worm
on the other hand will likely fall back
into the role of cold-blooded warrior
fueled by the death of missandei he'll
be wanting revenge and if daenerys
chooses to use dragons and it means a
few civilians will die along the way
i'm sure he'll be okay with it we have
this shot of john arriving at
dragonstone with varus accompanying him
the last we saw of him he was riding off
with davos but i don't see davos in this
picture
it could be that he's one of the men in
the back and we just can't see him
he's staying on the ship in the
background or that this shot takes place
in an entirely different part of the
episode outside the gates of king's
landing we have the leader of the golden
company harry strickland
he leads his band of mercenaries who are
being paid by cersei with money on loan
from the iron bank
now i do think there will be a battle
between the golden company and the
armies of the north
but don't hold it against them if they
somehow change allegiances or if the
iron bank somehow comes back into play
remember the golden company fights only
for money and the iron bank wants to
side with
the winner so anything is within the
realm of possibility for what strickland
will be up to next episode
now i do want to take one last moment to
discuss this picture which can also be
seen in the preview
and it's euron's shock in the scene that
has fans speculating that drogon has
brought
one or several of his offspring dragons
remember in season 5 drogon leaves dany
for much of the season
and is glimpsed by jorah and tyrion
flying over the ruins of the valerian
peninsula
some speculate that it was this time
away from dany that drogon laid eggs
that will appear sometime in this
episode
dragons can reproduce asexually and on
the actor who plays euron's instagram he
leaves the following line in regards to
episode 5.
you might see a dragon or two or none
but what are your thoughts for the
remaining two episodes are we about to
go down in a ball of flames or will game
of thrones deliver us the epic ending
we've been waiting eight seasons for
make sure to give the video a like and
subscribe since i have more game of
thrones videos on the way
you can also follow me on twitter at
thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much